im internet gibt es leider immer noch
gefakte kriminelle werbung in der unter
anderem ich scheinbar für bitcoin werbe
kompletter beschiss ganz wichtig dass
sie das wissen
tatsächlich gibt es nur eine
geschäftsidee die ich uneingeschränkt
empfehlen kann
eröffnen sie noch heute ein corona
testzentrum alles was sie brauchen es
ein zelt 23 arbeitslose in weißen
kitteln plus eine bierbank fähig abends
schreibst du eine beliebige zahl auf dem
zettel was weiß ich 1000 es mal 18 euro
schickst du dich an die kassenärztliche
vereinigung hat schon wieder reicher
geworden ja nur geld drucken ist
leichter bestimmt gar nicht geld drucken
es schwerer zur wahrheit gehört wir alle
wir alle haben gemerkt hat wegen zu viel
bürokratie im pandemie management
deswegen hat jens spahn seine test
verordnung hat eben mal etwas schneller
hin gehandelt buchstäblich keiner hat
darüber nachgedacht wie man das mit dem
testen kontrolliert und so was lockt
natürlich kriminelle an
ist ja klar sparen sagt was wollt ihr
denn die staatsanwaltschaften ermitteln
doch jetzt ja aber nur weil
investigative medien mal mitgezählt
haben
ein leerer parkplatz am stadtrand von
köln in diesem bus wurden am vorigen
freitag weniger als 80 menschen auf cora
getestet doch der betreiber die bochumer
firma medical meldet für diesen tag 977
tests an das düsseldorfer
gesundheitsministerium mehr als das
zehnfache alter spruch wo ist der bus
mit den leuten die wirklich getestet
wurden die firma medical hatte 54
testzentren in 36 städten
vielleicht wollen sie ja auch schon mal
nicht da kann gut sein
die mehrzahl der zentren sind natürlich
seriös klar aber wie könnte man denn in
zukunft den unseriösen vielleicht doch
mal auf die schliche kommen also in
einer 200 testkits
angefordert hat oder bezahlt hat und
nachher 400 tests abrechnet ist es halt
ein bisschen schwierig das zu
rechtfertigen das könnte den ansatzpunkt
sein für eine kontrolle wirklich könnte
ein anhaltspunkt sein ganz heiße spur
sherlock holmes beziehungsweise
pressesprecher von jens sparen sparen
hat fürs kontrollieren jetzt unter
anderem die gesundheitsämter ins spiel
gebracht worauf die sinngemäß gesagt
haben es total lieb hast du an uns denkt
jens aber wir sind eigentlich auch so
schon ganz gut ausgelastet und keine
buchprüfer dasselbe sagt die
kassenärztliche vereinigung irgendwer
macht bestimmt zur not kontrolliert
einfach der dänische geheimdienst die
wissen eh alles wahrscheinlich auch über
diesen fall
ich habe den test ja dann doch nicht
gemacht weil es mir zu voll war eine
teststation und bin nach hause gefahren
und irgendwann hatte ich gemütlich im
garten saß guck ich auf mein handy und
sehe die nachricht von der teststation
dass man test negativ ist
wie praktisch ist das denn so würde ich
mir meine darmspiegelung auch mal
wünschen
es ist so leicht mit dem finger auf
einen staat zu zeigen der für
unsichtbare test bezahlt hat aber das
passiert tatsächlich schneller als man
denkt zum beispiel bei der heute show
oder testet seit wochen ein arbeitsloser
pantomime hat keiner gemerkt so gut war
der typ fuchs schutz mit plexiglas das
sagt total echt aus wir dachten noch
wahr ist ja gut das tut ja überhaupt
nicht weh aber dann kam raus die ganzen
tests waren überhaupt nicht real nicht
real
nur das geld das er gekriegt hat das war
echt keine frage es ist immer ärgerlich
wenn steuergeld verbrannt wird aber
wirklich unverantwortlich ist bei dieser
geschichte sie einfach man bei uns so
ein testzentrum hochziehen kann
folgende schritte sind notwendig erst
muss man online ein einstündiges
schulungs video gucken dann das war es
schon
mehr ist nicht alles drei mann zelt im
garten aufbauen und los geht das wie bei
diesem studenten aus lübeck in seinem
testzentrum war eine angebliche ärztin
mit dem boot drl drl habe so erzählt
frau albrecht keine schutzkleidung
getragen und den rachenabstrich von der
wange genau
jetzt hat die falsche doktoren zwar
ihren job im testcenter verloren aber
damit kann sie ja immer noch
familienministerin werden mit solchem
fachpersonal können natürlich jederzeit
positive negativ getestet werden das ist
brandgefährlich von den hygienischen
zuständen in manchen zentren war ganz zu
schweigen
hier zum beispiel sehen aus wie aus
einer rtl 2 messi doku ist aber ein
testcenter in einem kölner kiosk da
haben sich sogar die ratten beschwert
überall wird getestet tatsächlich sogar
in bordellen kein witz bordelle
andererseits warum nicht körpernahe
dienstleistung halt besser als vor dem
ungeschulten studenten penetriert zu
werden finde ich
manche anbieter testen aus dem fenster
ihrer privatwohnung raus
da fällt mir ein warum testen nicht
hauptsächlich diese rentner die sowieso
immer am fenster hängen und aufpassen
eingeschränktes halteverbot freundchen
ich zeig dir einen moment negativ
vergisst ich keine angst er benutzt die
stäbchen maximal dreimal jens spahn
musste sich also wieder einiges anhören
diese woche ich habe junge kaum einer
kriegt so viel ab in der pandemie
trotzdem gibt es in deutschland wir
haben das mal recherchiert tatsächlich
einen jens spahn fanclub wirklich
vorsitzender ist matthias matschke
apotheker aus frankfurt herr matschie
sie sind also immer noch fan ja sowas
von also später sie hier
ich trage jens spahn t shirts die
schlaffe in jens spahn bettwäsche und
ich stehe jeden morgen als erstes hier
an meinem verein ein ketzer an für den
besten gesundheitsminister der welt
heiliger jens sorge für uns in der not
der wege mir geht das so dichand wie die
ganzen erbsenzähler so auf dem jens
krage mir apotheke wir haben nicht
vergessen was der mann für uns getan hat
kurz vor weihnachten als wir fb2 masken
an die wilde rabe verteilt haben die
apotheken bekommen dafür vom bund bis zu
6 euro pro maske überwiesen doch der
einkaufspreis soll nur bei rund einem
euro 22 gelegen haben der apotheker
schätzt dass er dafür am ende mehr als
400.000 euro vom steuerzahler erstattet
bekommt etwa das fünffache seiner kosten
für den einkauf der masten
sie hätten sich zitat dumm und dämlich
verdient so ein nicht namentlich
genannter apotheke ja das war ich habe
jetzt gesagt und wissen was ich stehe
dazu
ja stimmt auch damals haben sparens
eigene leute ihn vor den kosten gewarnt
wie jetzt bei den tests zentren sehen
sie und dass er sich stark über wehr
gesetzt hat was irgendwelche papst in
seinem laden da vor sich hin gabeln
dafür lieben ihn
der bub hat ein herz aus gold apropos
ich habe übrigens zufällig seit januar
einen goldenen porsche den habe ich aus
dankbarkeit ein war jens genannt erwäge
wir haben in deutschland doch weiß gott
genug bedenkenträger und sesselpupser
der sport mache ja einfach mal machen
und später fragen was das kostet gut
dass mein junior gegen kann schätzt
seinen salat studium finanzieren dank
der masken salle du sagst du einfach aus
aus kaarst ist genug da alter herr
matschie ich verstehe dass sie
persönlich fern sind aber als bürger
habe ich schon noch fragen auch wegen
der schweizer firma mx jens spahn hat
den 67 millionen masken für fünf euro 40
das stück abgekauft obwohl er damit
anderen firmen 450 als festpreis
ausgemacht hatte warum er weigert sich
das zu erklären oder die unterlagen
herauszugeben
er will wissen sie wie sich das für mich
an hört nicht mit krane auch da so hat
unser jens doch alles wesentliche gesagt
ich habe mich sehr bewusst nie ich nicht
beteiligt an der frage wer ist jetzt an
was schuld ich könnte auch viele
geschichten erzählen aus den letzten
zwölf monaten
ich glaube einfach nur es hilft nicht
und dennoch richtig nachgetreten das
kind ist in den brunnen gefallen also
beziehungsweise das geld ins klo
also ich werde ihm ewig dankbar sein
wenn schon sparen arbeitens nur zum spaß
sobald ich hier und kunde im tod greif
direkte man raus runder tag ich hätte
gerne in profen was den thron freund
matthias matschke
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leichter last ich hab die schnauze
voll auslasten abo da